est-ce qu'il faut interdire l'anonymat
sur les réseaux sociaux vaste question
et c'est la question d'ailleurs que
s'est posée bourdin direct sur rmc
aujourd'hui pour ouvrir un compte
twitter ou facebook très peu de
contrôles vous le savez le pseudo
d'ailleurs et presque la norme pour
tracer l'identité des auteurs de propos
haineux pour lever leur anonymat il faut
un huissier il faut engager une
procédure judiciaire c'est une démarche
fastidieuse et c'est très bien comme ça
pour certains parce que l'anonymat
permet aussi de garantir la sécurité par
exemple des lanceurs d'alert des
hauteurs de témoignage sensible
l'essayiste jean françois kahn veut un
mouvement pour mettre fin à cet anonymat
et emmanuel macron il voit aussi un
intérêt pour lutter contre les fausses
informations que cyber harcèlement
constituer un délit jusqu'à deux ans de
prison 30 mille euros d'amande et on a
un peu plus de 150000 signalement chaque
année aux autorités via la plateforme
pharos
alors je rappelle tout de même qu'il ya
un jeune sur quatre qui ne sait pas que
le cyber harcèlement constitue un délit
ils ignorent complètement un jeune sur
quatre le chiffre paraît énorme
vous êtes pour la levée de l'anonymat
damien aux contres alors moi je suis
contre interdire l'anonymat volley ball
à qu'on reste analyse surtout volare et
autres insectes sociaux interdire
l'anonymat pour moi ce serait une énorme
entraves à la liberté d'expression
pourquoi parce que dès lors que vous
êtes sous couvert d'anonymat vous pouvez
émettre des avis que vous ne pourriez
pas émettre si vous étiez avec votre nom
et votre prénom
d'accord mais je les mettrais tenter de
vous opposer oui mais si vous aussi vous
avez une conviction bruit vais la donner
avec votre non assumée à compliquer dans
les faits parce qu en fait lorsque vous
appartenait à une entreprise votre
employeur va pouvoir ensuite vous flics
et sur les réseaux sociaux et voir par
exemple peu quels sont vos avis
politique quels sont vos avis sur tel ou
tel sujet bref il va pouvoir faire un
véritable flicage idéologique et ça va
ouvrir la porte à toutes les
discriminations
donc pour cette raison moi je suis
contre et comment va-t-on mettre en
application cette mesure c'est la
question je me pose est ce que vous
allez devoir envoyer certains d'entre
eux posent aussi la question
effectivement pour les lanceurs d'alert
qui pourrait peut-être pas effectivement
alerter l'opinion publique parce qu' il
ne serait plus anonymes mais en revanche
on peut aussi se poser la question pour
tous ceux qui font ce qu'on appelle le
fameux cyber harcèlement tous ceux qui
sous couvert d'anonymat vont venir vous
insultez vont venir tenir des propos
homophobes et antisémites racistes etc
qu'est ce que c'est valérie vous avez
raison twitter jourd'hui et les réseaux
sociaux c'est devenu un véritable
déversoir de haine de racisme
d'homophobie
si on a rien à se reprocher si on n'a
pas l'intention de mettre des propos
diffamatoires
et ben pourquoi se cacher derrière
l'anonymat si on s'est du coup si on
commence à le faire c'est que là du coup
il ya un problème moi ça me fait penser
aux casseurs qui viennent cagoulés lors
des manifestations les pacifistes les
gilet jaune y viennent à visage
découvert eh ben c'est pareil ce qui se
cache derrière une cagoule
ils peuvent se cacher derrière un pseudo
et sa notion vous oppose le fait que par
exemple on veut dénoncer quelque chose
mais qu'on a peur pour sa sécurité
qu'est ce que vous répondez à cela moi
je pense que aujourd'hui on est dans un
pays libre avec une liberté d'expression
et qu'on a le droit aujourd'hui
pratiquement de tout dire non
jean-michel non non je suis pas d'accord
avec toi on n'a pas le droit de tout
dire justement qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui vont avoir peur de dire quelque
chose même si c'est vrai et donc moi
j'étais au début favorable à
l'interdiction est en réalité je rejoins
un peu diam damien ça permet à des gens
de s'exprimer sans avoir peur soit de se
faire à engueuler par son patron ou de
se faire repérer et vous voulez qu'on
conserve la donne et marge de conserve
l'anonymat mais qu'on facilite l'accès à
la levée de l'anonymat quand y'a un
problème sérieux au lieu de faire passer
par donc que les plateformes travailler
main dans la main et qui alors
totalement il ya besoin caroline mais ça
me paraît évident il faut lever
l'anonymat
c'est la seule façon on aura
d'identifier les gens de s'organiser de
savoir d'où vient d'où viennent les
informations de distinguer les gens et
puis vraiment l'argument majeur
macron et pour tim macron amoureuse et
que ça très bien de ce que vous en
pensez interdire l'anonymat sur les
réseaux sociaux vous a posé la question
toute la journée
vous êtes toujours interdire l'anonymat
69% et vous l'êtes compte à 31%